hey guys how's it going it's Justine
welcome back to my kitchen I heard you
guys you were telling me to get back in
the kitchen but that was not like an
insult way like you wanted more baking
videos so guess what we're here we're in
the kitchen and normally this is not a
place that you want me because I'm not
good at cooking I'm okay at baking I've
gotten a lot better over the years but
today I'm making something really
exciting I wanted to make my sister a
birthday cake her birthday is actually
today today I'm gonna be making her a
grilled cheese cake grilled cheese is
one of our favorite foods and we also
love cake so basically making a grilled
cheese cake is a dream come true for
both of us
should I make this in a blender do you
guys miss the blender you do miss the
blender so a lot of you guys might be
new here I'm Justine nice to meet you
sometimes I make tech videos that's
actually my favorite thing to make I
also I'm gonna try to bake it's usually
not good oh you might be also wondering
are you making me pick in a blender I
really don't even have an answer for you
this just this is what I started doing
here we are still doing it we're gonna
make her a basic white cake super moist
anytime as if I made a freaking cake and
I can't remember what goes into it okay
now if you're making a cake in the
blender I would recommend putting in all
of the wet ingredients first
this looks dirty 2/3 excellent 1/3 cup
of vegetable oil raise your hand if
you've made a cake in a blender before I
don't see any other hands
[Music]
okay that's good enough
okay need to grease these up I'm gonna
grease him up like a greased pig it's I
think I may have told this story before
but I grew up in a town that was it was
kind of small my high school was really
small and basically was in the middle of
a farm people used to bring pigs to like
it was like a senior prank and they
would brace them up and like butter and
oil and then let them go in this school
grease it up like a grease high school
pig oh this is really soupy probably
shouldn't have mixed it so much so these
are gonna be our buns for our bread not
buttons just spread we're gonna put
these in the oven for threw the Box away
but it's probably 25 to 30 minutes maybe
one of the complaints that I have about
the home pot is Siri can only set one
timer is that some sort of technology
that is so new that you pants that more
than one timer and then we're gonna get
our icing ready our cakes are cooking
baking whatever now we need to eat our
icing so I need to have some yellow
icing and some brown icing for kind of
like the crust and oh wait the yellow
would be the cheese so I need two yellow
icing a crust hmm
I need another bowl actually this is
probably way more icing than I'm gonna
need I can always get more on Amazon
Prime now this will be our cheesy Center
it's going well so far
I think cheese is orange like it's not
what the color that I was good thinking
this looks like some off branch that you
shouldn't eat real this is like buffalo
sauce so I think that's a nice color for
our cheese it's definitely not exactly
what I had in mind but this will be our
Brown
no no okay
something is not looking right a case of
red yep I wish I had magical powers I
could fix I do have magical powers it's
called editing so this one I didn't want
it to be a little bit lighter because
it's gonna be like the bread like a
slight toasting no this is a better
working with the chip pages mixed some
icing that's good enough yeah you think
that's bread to look at bread it's
lighter than the other one yeah you
should just say yeah that looks like
bread it's what I was thinking
guys I need you to say yeah that looks
like bread you guys should go comment on
every YouTube video that's posted today
and say yeah that looks like bread we
have got our icing sets we've got our
cakes I let them cool and now we're
gonna make this freaking grilled cheese
normally I would probably try to level
these cakes but since this isn't
something that I really want to be very
even I'm not going to I want this to be
a very cheesy goodness for Jenna she's
not even here so she's not even get to
really enjoy it so I'm gonna have to
save it for her this actually is a
perfect color I think Jenna's are really
gonna enjoy this it's never to flop on
put on Oh
[Music]
this actually this this is even a better
grilled cheese like not putting any
icing on it so now that I'm seeing what
we're working with and thinking about
things very differently I'm gonna ice
this up and I'll see you guys after this
sped up video okay definitely probably
should have made the crust darker
sometimes you need to just make the best
out of any situation that you're in so
that's what I tell myself cuz I don't
want to make more icing feel like this
needs a little bit of texture so if I go
like this it's gonna look like it's
gonna look like bread and in my mind
this was gonna look incredible in
reality I don't think Jenna's gonna
enjoy my birthday cake that I made of
her me think it looks like a girl cheese
it also could look like a surface of a
planet well here it is guys this is
Jenna's birthday cake it is a grilled
cheese if you're just skipping to the
end of the video and then watch the
whole rest of it I'm gonna go deliver
this to her now but in the meantime make
sure you guys to subscribe we sort of
hit the belt so you'll be notified when
I post new videos so let's go to Jenna's
I'm gonna put this in my car no didn't
thinking about that yesterday I made you
a birthday cake I was gonna drive it to
your house when I thought about traffic
and I didn't drive into the house I'd
like to present you a birthday cake did
you make you made it oh I made it I made
it I didn't eat is it edible
yeah I didn't wash my hands do you know
what this is I'd say it's like a
hamburger but I guess I'm eat Hampson
looks like a girl there's our girl
cheese a hamburger is not even not even
hamburger look at me and you know what I
mean it's um it looks like a like a
sandwich at the burger it's a it's not
like a burger well like when I see a
butt like when I saw this I thought like
a bun and you know the cheese melts over
but I thought it's for me so is it a
girl - you never cheese that's that
makes sense this must've taken you dazed
I didn't write your name on because I
didn't want it to be like I wanted to be
look like a girl cheese look no it looks
like girl cheese help you put sideways
that looks cool
I'm impressed with your work it looks
good it does look good I'm surprised you
wanna get a close-up of it yeah yeah
yeah yeah let me zoom in so you think
like should I pick it up like a sandwich
you should really have from the center
or hard yeah after the center it's been
in the fridge happy birthday happy
birthday out of her Channel yeah there's
a super juicy video on my channel for my
birthday oh I did something dumb you did
she hasn't done it yet I'm going to do
something dumb
[Music]